ist die abstandsregeln nach den
sommerferien aufgehoben
familienministerin franziska giffey hat
sich dafür ausgesprochen dass nach dem
sommerferien wieder normalbetrieb in
kitas und schulen herrschen soll
wenn die infektionszahlen das zu lassen
ist das der richtige weg darüber möchte
ich jetzt sprechen mit heinz peter
meidinger präsident des deutschen
lehrerverbandes der mir jetzt live
zugeschaltet ist herr meidinger halten
sie das für einen guten vorschlag jeden
soll ein vorschlag ist werden muss wir
sehen uns ja alle nach mehr an
normalität wieder im schulbetrieb
allerdings viel mehr dafür noch alle
voraussetzungen haben jene konzept
derzeit an den schulen das beruht auf
der abstandsregelung und wir haben noch
kein neuer zucchini konzept das heißt
sie halten den vorschlag nicht für
realistisch was müsste passieren damit
das wirklich wieder normalbetrieb in den
schulen herrschen kann ja also es
natürlich wenn wir einen impfstoff haben
und dass wir sozusagen der schnellste
und einfachste weg wieder von diesen
abstandsregelungen wegzukommen
wenn das noch länger dauern sollte kann
man tatsächlich darüber nachdenken ob
man nicht auch ein neues konzept
entwickelt dass nur die heißen wenn sich
die klassenzimmer wieder füllen also
ganze klassen zurückkehren da dass wir
die klassen voneinander isolieren müssen
damit eben das infektionsgeschehen
kontrollierbar bleibt wir müssen auch
darüber nachdenken über lüftungs
regelungen und gegebenenfalls auch über
eine masken pflicht im klassenzimmer
was fordern sie dann als lehrer konkret
also ich fordere dass die politik ihre
hausaufgaben macht also man kann nicht
einfach ankündigen
wir werden nach den sommerferien wieder
normalen schulbetrieb haben und dafür
keine voraussetzungen schafft man sie
wir brauchen ja nur an gesundheitsschutz
gehört auch ein neues hygiene konzept
und das heißt die
kultusministerkonferenz muss sich jetzt
auf den hosenboden setzen und dieses
wiki ein konzept vorliegen und es ist
natürlich in einer gewissen weise auch
ein großes
risiko wenn sich die infektionszahlen
bei kindern und jugendlichen in den
schulen dann stark sanieren muss man
dann auch eher und wieder die notbremse
sie den rückwärtsgang einlegen und zum
schicht betrieb zurückkehren
danke schön herr meidinger